you know so I've been in a lot of
conversations lately and people are like
yeah Gary you're right
you know if you do what you love who
cares about the cash right the
fulfillment of being happy and going to
work and doing what you love is so great
you know it's been very common wisdom or
it's been brought up quite a bit and
kind of confirmed that you know that
people that leave high-paying jobs
should go do what they love and they'll
live a more fulfilling life but what
people don't talk about at all I rarely
hear people talk about this is something
I believe immensely and something that I
want to push people to start thinking
about especially in this economic
downturn I actually fundamentally
believe that if you end up leaving a
corporate job or working for the man or
doing something that you hate and start
doing something that you love and at a
much lower cost in the beginning whether
it's you're working a nine-to-five job
and doing it at night or you can do it
and monetize it but you're not making as
much money as you used to as a lawyer or
a doctor that you'll end up making so
much more money to you know that's the
thing Mott Maddy you know people like
yeah I do it
awesome Gary you're right I'm pumped who
cares about the cash I'm in a little
awesome life yeah and you're gonna make
more money it might not happen right
away but you have to understand when you
love it when it comes out of your face
when it pours out of your body when you
love it breathe it live it every second
you build bigger things you put more
into it you don't just work 9:00 to 5:00
you don't just live for your vacations
or your weekends you're gonna be second
every moment and you know what happens
when you work and you work hard and oh
by the way you like it so you're working
smart and you know it cuz it's your
hobby or your passion you crush it so
yeah you can leave and make less money
but ultimately gonna make more so you
can be happy and make more money that
sounds good to me